We're back with the hosts of "The Talk",
and these ladies are experts
when it comes to the art of thoughtful, lively conversation
and we're gonna dive into some hot topics.
But not too hot, I don't ever wanna be super controversial.
So this is warm topics.
(audience applauds)
Warmish.
We love it.
Yeah, tepid and safe.
Okay.
Okay, so a new Cosmo article
says that the latest trend is single people
forming opinions about potential partners
based on only one characteristic.
And ruling people out because they don't like
that one quality.
Example, height.
Anyone have a thought?
Anyone ever been a mono-manic dater?
No!
Gotta be open.
Open to all sorts of people.
Yeah.
All different shapes and sizes.
The most interesting people come
in the most unexpected ways, I've found.
And it's more about the soul
and the person and how interesting they are,
how passionate they are,
how their hands feel against your body.
(women exclaiming)
That's a warm topic, I didn't go too deep.
I do think it's easy to do that though.
Like it is easy to read something and be like,
oh, well they do this or something,
and write them off right away.
But everyone that I've always dated
and fallen in love with,
it's because overtime you get to know that person
and then you get to know all the best little,
great, little juicy things about that person.
No one's perfect, you know?
Yeah, no one's perfect.
And to go on something like height,
or he's bald or whatever,
it's like they could have the greatest soul in the world
and you're just letting them go
because they're short or no hair?
It's like, no.
I do have the one thing, Drew.
What is it?
I have the one thing.
You cannot date me if you're already married.
Boo!
Well, yeah-
See, but nobody ever asks that question.
And I tell women, the first thing you ask a man,
are you married?
'Cause a man will say in your face, I'm separated.
Well, do your wife know she's separated?
(audience laughs)
That's why you have to ask.
So on your dating profile,
it will say, Sheryl-ed, not a cuckled.
You better say it.
I'm glad you said the world,
'cause it's not gonna sound as dignified
as you just said it,
if I said the world.
(audience laughs)
Not to cuckled.
I agree.
In this weird swipe-y world,
it's like people are just judging on a photo,
and Amanda, I'm so with you.
Like Andy Warhol says,
"Fall in love with your eyes closed".
Sharon, you're absolutely right.
And I feel like it's getting to know someone
that makes you go,
you know what, A plus B equals C,
and on and on.
And when you're just looking at a picture...
And by the way, all these men on these dating profiles
are so quippy and ambiguous,
you can't get to know somebody.
I will tell you,
if I had to meet Jonathan on a swipe-y swipe-y app,
I wouldn't have swiped, he's not my type in air quotes,
and I've known him since we were kids.
He had these big glasses,
and I remember I was not checking for him in high school
'cause he had these big old glasses,
and now I'm so glad I got over that thing
and that I got to meet this man in person,
because he's my person.
And I just think if you get stuck on the shallow stuff
in the swipe-y swipe, you never gonna get to the good stuff.
Yeah, but everybody now is stuck on the shallow.
That's why they take pictures of themselves constantly.
So it's like everybody just cares about the way you look.
I mean, didn't you have a time where
when you were younger, you saw a photograph and went,
that's a nice looking guy,
or that's a guy I wanna meet.
Sure.
I don't know if it would be easy
to look at it on a gadget,
but I will tell you,
I've torn out plenty of pictures in a magazine
and said, this is my type.
You let Lenny Kravitz walk up in here,
he could get it.
(women laughing)
I'd like to see that mood board, Sheryl.
And by the way, Elaine, everything you just said
reminded me of like, "13 Going On 30".
(audience laughs)
I know, it's very rom-com.
Great movie, by the way.
(woman applauding)
It's true, we all wish we could like-
It's very rom-com.
Your story is just the dream,
that you have the perspective
and you find the right one.
Okay, next topic, Jennifer Coolidge revealed
that she couldn't decide between two men
on a Hawaiian vacation,
so she pretended to have an identical twin,
and then date both of them.
And she dated two guys for a week.
Oh my god, I couldn't believe this story.
Sharon, thoughts.
Well, firstly, I adore her.
She is so funny.
And good luck to her.
Whoa, I never thought of doing that ever.
(women laughing)
And it's way too late to try now.
But I think that's a great idea.
I think it's ingenious.
Holiday fun.
It's ingenious.
Yes!
I could never date two people at once, that's hard.
Have you ever slept with two people?
Not at once, no.
I'm like a one person kind of person.
Like it's really hard for me,
'cause I'm so committed to things,
like I give everything to anything
that's in front of me.
You give it all.
But I wouldn't be able to.
It wouldn't feel right to me.
Could you do that?
I have dated two people at once, and it was fun.
Oh, it was so fun!
(women cheering)
No, I had like dinner with him,
and then he like put me in a taxi,
and I just went right around the corner
and had drinks with the next one.
(women applauding)
I love it!
That's what I'm talking about.
Angel!
Did everybody know and was everybody okay with it?
Oh no.
No, no, no.
No, they don't know?
No, but I mean, no one was serious,
this was not committed.
Gotcha, gotcha.
I mean, but yes, it was fun.
It was only a small part of my life,
but it was a good time.
Absolutely.
And I try to split them up in time zones,
so it's really not the same date.
(audience laughs)
Amanda, I did that once too.
I went to a lunch with one gentleman,
and he ended up kissing me,
and then I drove to the next thing,
and I was like, wow, twofer!
Great day!
(women laughing)
Way to go, Drew!
I love it.
I really understand why you guys have so much fun together
and I don't wanna leave right now.
I wanna stay with you guys.
Don't leave us!
You can always come back!
Come over to us!
Come over and visit us more often.
Yeah!
Actually, no joke, can we make that a date?
As soon as it is safe,
I would love to come visit you guys.
Yes!
Come on over.
Please.
Yeah, come on over.
That would be so fun!
Sure.
And then, Elaine, we could do this for real.
(women cheering)
(women laughing)
Okay, thank you so much,
the hosts of "The Talk".
My goodness, okay, I guess it's gotta end.
I don't want it to,
but weekends on CBS, 2:00 P.M. Eastern.
(upbeat music)